[Music]
thank you
morning everybody it's seven o'clock
here in the UK you are very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at Sky
news this morning 5 000 pounds to scrap
your old boiler and make your home
Greener with a heat pump but that cash
will only help a tiny fraction of homes
in England so what about the rest and
how hard is it to make the switch you'll
be joined by the international trade
secretary and Marie trebellion shortly
plus we'll speak to the head of the
climate crisis Advisory Group in that's
the David King also to come for you this
morning with daily covered cases rising
to the highest point in three months
yesterday there's criticism the Boost of
vaccine rollout is happening just too
slowly the spiritual professor of
primary care and public health and
that's at 20 past eight in addition
we're going to be speaking to the
comedian and Pub landlord El Murray
about his new series on Sky history
looking at Britain's military past
that's at a 20 to 10. it's Tuesday the
19th of October the reveals the grants
of five thousand pounds for some
households to scrap their old gas boiler
so the government can hit climate
targets but families won't be forced to
do it
could sites like the Green Park turbine
in Reading become more common we'll find
out later when the government's expected
to release full details of its Net Zero
by 2050 strategy
the coal plants they can all close in
your in your State's not going to close
them stay you can't cause them
reliability
we need reliability
I managing to climb we track down the
West Virginia senator who's holding up
America's progress on tackling climate
change
strolling to a station on the morning of
the attack the CCTV that Sky News
understands shows the suspect into David
amos's murder
[Music]
let down by the police the parents of a
woman thought to have been killed by a
man she had reported for stalking speak
for the first time to Sky News
we wouldn't have let her go up to the
field on that day on her own I'm prior
to that and wouldn't let her go anywhere
on her own after that I think they've
let her down big time
emotional scenes as thousands of
prisoners arrested during the military
Takeover in Myanmar are freed
[Music]
om good morning people will be able to
apply for Grants of several thousand
pounds to ditch their gas boiler and
change to heating that produces lower
emissions it's all part of the
government's plan to hit its climate
targets but families won't be forced to
do it as our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clarke reports
heating our homes with gas is one of the
single biggest contributions each of us
makes to global warming
hinging that will take time and a lot of
money but some like Viv chalice are
already enjoying the benefits
it's going to make a lot of difference
especially to people like myself
pensioners young families that haven't
got a lot of money coming in to be able
to see a reduction in the price of the
bills coming down it's going to make a
big big difference
her home was one of the first in the
neighborhood to be upgraded by her
Housing Association Clarion and a
government funding scheme here they're
putting a thick wadge of insulation on
the outside of the house the front door
has been moved forward to accommodate
that and triple glazed windows are being
sealed into the property from the
outside
more insulation an airtight membrane and
to manage condensation and mechanical
ventilation system together that keeps
the house warm and dry
it's the work required for a home like
this to have its boiler replaced with a
more low carbon heat pump a process the
government wants to replicate at scale
with its new strategy suggesting it
might phase out gas boilers entirely by
2035. but there's a lot of work ahead
around 65 percent of the UK's 29 million
homes will need Energy Efficiency
upgrades to meet Net Zero targets some
60 could cost less than a thousand
pounds to make heat pump ready but the
remainder of upgrades will cost much
more with the overall bill for Energy
Efficiency some 55 billion by 2050.
given the scale of the shift the
government will also have to price
energy in a way to persuade people to
change
a very very simple move that would
change how we think about gas boilers
versus
heat just make electricity Cheaper by
putting those policy costs somewhere
else
the other thing to add is there's never
been a better time to do that and reduce
electricity bills than a time where
we're facing an energy price spike and
people are really struggling with their
bills and will do through the winter and
into the spring getting all of us to
give up on gas is a big ask we have the
technology to do it the trick is
deploying it in a way that's affordable
fare and most of all keeps us warm Tom
Clark Sky News
I'm Marie Rebellion for the government
with us now good morning to you Mr
Valium we only have a limited amount of
time this morning so let's cancel
through
um 10 000 pounds to install the heat
pumps only five thousand pounds as
um an incentive so why should people do
it
so this is a fantastic announcement that
the Prime Minister has made today and
it's going to help as we move through
this transition in our domestic heating
arrangements to help those uh who want
to crack on now and indeed over many
years ahead to change their boilers to a
clean energy solution I don't know if
you know okay but I've been restoring a
house and I've just putting in hydrogen
ready boiler into mine because of the
nature of the house I live in but we're
already seeing a huge amount of
investors billions of pounds going
through as your package spoke about the
local authorities who are investing for
those who have the greatest need to
improve the installation in their homes
and the least personal resources to do
it so we're already making huge strides
for those most in need to make sure that
because in this in this journey that
we're doing it's about reducing the
amount of energy we use if we can as
well as of course we're using clean
energy so making houses better insulated
as well as then having heat pumps as
people move to those clean energy
solutions is all part of this enormous
and really far-reaching package in the
Heat and build strategy today and has
the heat pump reduced your bills
so I'm still restoring the house but uh
it will absolutely help and one of the
things I've done also is to insulate him
and I'm in a very old northumbrian house
to insulate it because I want to reduce
the amount of energy that I use overall
that of course as the ultimate is as we
move to building Net Zero homes in
future new homes will be much much more
efficient but for millions of us who
live in old houses that retrofitting
that insulation and then having the
Clean Energy Solutions that we use to
generate the power that we use will be
critically important but this is a
journey it is a transition when we talk
about NetZero this is a journey we're
all on together and the prime minister
is committed to give a framework that
means we can all participate as Citizens
in helping meet that Net Zero challenge
okay let's counter through uh 450
million pound uh pledge green
organizations and the green party saying
that's only covering 90 000 heat pumps
we've got 29 million households in the
UK
um
how you're going to pay for the rest of
them
so as I said for the a lot of the local
Authority homes there is already a huge
scheme of billions of pounds being used
to help them to decarbonize to insulate
and indeed to change their heating
systems uh this uh 450 million which is
committed over the next three years will
help those who really want to crack on
to give them effectively a cost Mutual
opportunity to change the gas boiler
they have now to a heat pump or some
other Clean Energy Solution as I've done
with a hydrogen ready boiler so that we
are moving towards that so I think this
is a great first part of the program but
for those most in need there is already
a huge local Authority scheme underway
okay so I'm sure your lovely house in
Northumberland has got a very nice
Garden that you've had to dig up for the
heat pump a lot of homes don't have
Gardens so how do they make it work
so no I haven't got a heat pump I've got
a hydrogen ready uh boiler so like a gas
boiler excellent good for you what about
your job we need to dig up their Gardens
for a heat pump they have a garden what
happens to them what's the plan there so
a lot of the a lot of the heat pumps
will be air source heat pumps which are
if you like the opposite of fridge and
you can clip them on the outside of a
home and they draw in they use a
differential heat system to help Source
it and that's what will be used for many
and that can be used in Flats as well as
houses it doesn't require a ground
Source heat pump which what you're
describing which will be about digging
out Gardens
excellent um what about people who don't
want to get rid of the gas boiler is it
going to be a voluntary scheme
so in the short term uh of course this
is a voluntary scheme but every you know
10 to 15 years and I've spoken to my
local gas teams about this we all get a
new boiler there is a changing of the
equipment doesn't last forever so as
part of as I say the transition this
journey to Net Zero as we as domestic
citizens make changes to our homes these
support Frameworks these Financial
Frameworks are there but also we will be
driving those changes in regulations so
that the next time you maybe want to
change the boiler in your home the
opportunity will be to either have a
heat pump or indeed perhaps as I have a
hydrogen ready boiler so that this will
be part of the transition and the normal
part of things in the same way that when
you buy you know your next car you will
probably buy a net zero emissions car
parts and electric vehicle because this
is part of the cycle of uh you know
renewing the assets that we have as part
of our daily lives yeah staggeringly
more expensive though than a gas spoiler
aren't they so if people are thinking
about what to do like the boilers come
to its end of life over the next 18
months they can still buy a gas boiler
if they want to
there will there will be a point in
which that changes but yes for now
that's the case which is why this is a
transition as I say but the key point of
course like we know with so many things
is that at the moment the uh heat pumps
are relatively uh small volumes in
production but of course as more of us
uh take them on and invest in them the
cost of production will come down and
therefore like all volume sales they all
become much cheaper and there's some
really impressive commitments to some of
the engine companies who want to drive
that change to leaning in themselves to
make sure that they can help customers
make that change effectively just time
for another couple of questions this
morning hopefully you'll come and see us
soon
um the boosters so from boilers to boost
does the booster jobs not much of an
uptake on that why do you think it is
what are you going to do about it
so we've seen I think over three million
uh take up the booster jab already and
uh children of course through schools
are getting theirs and there's uh more
announcements this week to help boost
that posture but I think really
importantly the booster jav kobit is you
know is one that we are encouraging
people to take and I've just had
actually a text yesterday from my doctor
encouraging me to go and have mine six
months after your second jab that you
will have had earlier in the year uh you
have the opportunity to come to that and
of course a flu jab as well so we're
encouraging all those who are vulnerable
anyone like me who's over 50 please do
make sure that you get your booster jab
to help make sure that we are able to
continue living in the factum you know
new and will be able to do as a result
of the incredible vaccine program that
we've rolled out this
I'm significantly older than you Mr
Valley and I've already had mine and my
um flu jab as well and the flu jab hurt
more just so if anybody's a little bit
worried about the booster it doesn't
hurt at all uh while we've got you let
me ask you about with your hat on for
Secretary of State for international
trade we thought that this Aussie deal
had been done that's certainly the
impression we were given uh by Liz trust
when she was in charge at trade but on
Friday the Australian trade secretary
left London without one what's going on
so
so the way our trade deals work is we
start with a because we're doing this uh
on our own merits where there is no you
know we're not past the EU anymore is we
launch a consultation and we ask our
businesses and citizens what they want
to see from a trade deal uh and uh then
we discuss it and then we publish what's
called an agreement in principle that's
what was announced in June by my
predecessor Liz truss from there that
was a 14-page document that has to be
turned into a 2 600 page document of
legal text so that's what we've been
working on since then and uh the
Australian trade Minister Dan tihan who
was here last week uh was here he and I
were going through some of the sort of
uh final details to make sure that uh
both sides are happy with the complexity
because when these years are in place we
want our businesses on both sides to be
able to know that these are robust legal
documents and that we can get absolutely
the best trading activity and all the
other things that are in this deal are
really exciting advisor to work as
effectively as possible so we're just
about there on the legal text and then
we'll be able to publish it shortly
fantastic need to let you go good to
talk to you this morning speak to you
soon thank you
thanks so much Kate bye bye-bye thank
you uh hearing from the Prime Minister
actually later on about 9 20. this
morning also hearing um how the
government intends to cut those climate
emissions to Net Zero by 2050. the
strategy is expected to focus on the
UK's need for more clean green energy
sources and a new nuclear power project
well our reporter Aisha Zaid is with us
now good morning to you I know you're at
the wind turbine I think in Reading
massive thing if anybody's seen it on
the M4 I'm sure we'll see it when it
gets a bit lighter where you are but um
that is one of the alternative energy
sources that the government will be
talking about I'm guessing
yeah that's right I think we can expect
more discussion on wind power today
these details will really underpin how
the UK aims to deliver on its commitment
to becoming Net Zero by 2050 we expect
measures which will help create what's
been described as a secure homegrown
clean energy sector eliminating the need
for fossil fuels and reducing Reliance
on gas of course we've very recently
seen the knock-on effects of volatile
gas prices globally now we can
anticipate a number of measures to be
discussed I think one of the key areas
is likely to be the UK's need for a new
nuclear project a nuclear power project
currently around a fifth of the
electricity generated here is comes from
nuclear power but the problem lies in
the fact that of the reactors that are
currently being used they're all
expected to be retired by 2035 and then
of course I think we can expect to see
many more measures discussing how we can
increase the use of other clean energy
sources so all these details expected
later today okay lovely thanks a lot
thank you Sky News has obtained CCTV
footage that we understand shows the
man's suspected of killing Sir David
Amos on the morning of the attack
25 year olds Ali Ali who has been
arrested on suspicion of the murder of
Sir David is seen walking slowly along
the pavement on Friday morning the video
footage was filmed from outside a
convenience store on Highgate Road at 8
44 A.M
Ali who lives in North London was
initially arrested at the scene of the
attack on suspicion of murder and has
since been detained under the terrorism
legislation Act
MPS from all parties sat shoulder to
shoulder at a service Mr David by 800
MPS and peers dressed in black filed
into Saint Margaret's Church next to
Westminster Abbey in silence
[Music]
South End will be granted City status as
a tribute to Sir David the Prime
Minister has announced
the actor Robert Carlyle has paid
tribute to the murder to MP all six
episodes of Series 2 Cobra cyber War
were due to be released on Friday in
fact they were but Skye has taken the
decision to temporarily remove the final
three episodes from your box set
um sir David's death
is the reason for that we're told there
is a sensitive theme within the last
three episodes of season two
still to come on the program for you
after quarter to eight speaking to the
minister of Tourism for the Maldives
about the Staggering number of tourists
they've welcomed this year amid the
coronavirus pandemic
20 past eight will speak to a professor
of primary care and public health to
chat about the rising Kobe cases and
whether the booster vaccine rollout is
happening fast enough
and then at half base speaking to the
labor MP Sarah Owen about why she's
introducing a bill to extend paid
bereavementally to women who miscarry
before 24 weeks
foreign a woman sought to have been
killed by a man she'd reported for
stalking her was let down by the police
her parents of told Sky News 23 year old
Gracie Spinks was stabbed in the neck at
stables near her Chesterfield home in
June Gerard tub reports
was a music-loving 23 year old
furloughed during lockdown she took a
job in a Derbyshire Warehouse where a
supervisor became so infatuated with her
she reported him to the police
her best friend Ben she Gracie's parents
thought it had been resolved but four
months later she was dead what do you
know happened of that morning
um that
um a guy who Gracie had previously
reported to the police for stalking her
um approach to that morning and he
murdered her
Gracie was a keen Rider go on Gracie and
it was when Michael Sellers turned up at
her Livery stables in February that she
accused him of stalking she was found
fatally stabbed at the stables in June
and seller's body was found in a
neighboring field a few hours later
her family only then learned that knives
and acts and a note saying don't lie had
been found there six weeks earlier and
handed to the police
bag of weapons had been handed in on the
6th of May and as far as we know the
police didn't act upon it and join up
the darts basically from Grace's
complaints
um and yeah but other than that we've
not really heard from the police now so
we don't know
Derbyshire police say they're unable to
comment because of an investigation by
the independent office for police
conduct which says its investigation is
ongoing
Gracie's father believes she was let
down by the police
I'm going to put two and two together
and warned her about this therefore we
wouldn't have let her go up to the field
on that day on her own and prior to that
and wouldn't have let her go anywhere on
her own after that so uh
that's that's the view that I've got
with it I think they've let her down big
time today would have been Gracie's 24th
birthday and a vigil will be held
tonight at her graveside
her family is now campaigning for extra
funding to give each police force a
dedicated point of contact for stalking
complaints they want other women's
safety to be Gracie's Legacy
Gerard Sky News Chesterfield
slit tragedy no a mass release of
prisoners is underway in Myanmar becomes
after the country's military rulers
announced an amnesty for thousands of
people arrested for anti-government
activities during February's Army
takeover joining us is our southeast
Asia correspondent Siobhan Robbins hi
Siobhan so talk us through what's
happening
morning K really emotional scenes
outside prisons across Myanmar after
this amnesty which actually began last
night with some prisoners already being
released we've seen families who some of
them didn't even know if they'd ever see
their loved ones again who have gone for
months without word waiting desperate to
see if their family member is among
those 5 600 which we're told are being
released of course we don't actually
know if that will be the extent of the
people who are released or if it will
actually be smaller but why is this
happening well the big question is uh
it's really a political move by the
Junta leader because
um he has been excluded from a meeting
of Southeast Asian Nations which is
taking part place that's a massive shun
for him and it follows the asean special
Envoy um canceling a trip to Myanmar
because he wasn't allowed access to
speak to prisoners including ansan
tsuchi I think in terms of how important
this release is of course it's
absolutely important for people who
haven't seen their family members but in
terms of big Target prisoners I think
we're very unlikely to see the release
of someone like aung San tsuchi and
actually opponents say this is just a
distraction technique to try and get
foreign governments on board
interestingly the UN special rep on tour
Tom Andrews was saying that he believes
the military government is motivated by
three things money legitimacy and
getting weapons and by blocking access
to asean they basically blocked this
call for legitimacy so he's trying to
make these tentative steps to suggest
yes I am starting to release prisoners
what does it really mean in a country
where more than a thousand people have
already been killed by Security Forces
since February more than 9 000 people
have been arrested and violence is
continuing
okay thank you Sean thank you
looking at some of the other stories
making headlines for you here on the
breakfast show this Tuesday morning two
adults two children have been taken to
hospital after a house was destroyed by
an explosion in Scotland goodness me
look at those pictures residents in air
were evacuated Following last night's
blast that could be heard for miles
around three other homes were also badly
damaged police in Scotland say inquiries
are continuing into the cause of the
explosion
infrared light therapy could be helping
people live with dementia scientists in
Durham have used an infrared light on a
special helmet as part of a trial and
found improvements in the memory motor
function and processing skills of
participants
Donald Trump's filed a lawsuit in an
attempt to block a congressional
committee from obtaining White House
records of the capital riots the
committee is investigating how Trump's
supporters stormed the building in a
challenge to Joe Biden's win in January
of this year the former president claims
that the record request is a political
ploy
Australian police are continuing to
search for a four-year-old girl who went
missing from an Outback campsite on
Saturday Cleo Smith was holidaying with
her family at the blow Hills Campsite in
Mcleod around 560 miles north of Perth
British Army veteran on trial for
charges linked to a fatal shooting
during the Northern Ireland troubles has
died after Contracting covid-19
eight-year-old Dennis Hutchings denied
the attempted murder of 27 year old John
Pat Cunningham Mr Cunningham was fatally
shot in the back as he ran from an army
Patrol in the Tyrone Village of bembub
in 1974.
the British museum is to display the
world's oldest surviving map of the
Stars the 3006 Euro 3600 year old
neberus guide disc first discovered in
Germany in 1999 is considered one of the
most important archaeological finds of
the 20th century
now Kanye West has legally changed his
name to yay
after a Los Angeles Court approved his
application
in August the rapper formally requested
to change his name to yay
um citing personal reasons the 44 year
old first alluded to his plans to change
his name in 2018 when he tweeted
formerly known as Kanye West I am yay
for the benefit of any doubt I am K
almost one in three people in the music
industry lost their jobs as a result of
the pandemic according to a new report
the trade body UK music said 69 000 jobs
were wiped out as the sector struggled
with the devastating impact of covert
our AIDS our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer reports
[Music]
we literally just finished mastering
this new album
at the end of February and then the
whole world closed down Crooks
there was no time to plan the reality of
live music shutting down overnight meant
18 of the most challenging months of
Roxanne de bastian's career financially
and mentally my release got pushed back
all my live dates got canceled
so
that was quite a bleak moment
[Music]
and Roxanne was relatively lucky a new
report into what happened shows that in
the space of a year covered wiped out 69
000 music jobs that's almost one in
three and the industry's economic
contribution almost halved from 5.8
billion pounds in 2019 to 3.1 billion
last year
industry trade body UK music is calling
on the government to come up with a
recovery plan we need support from the
government to resolve that touring
crisis also we're looking at things like
vat we had vat reduced over the course
of the pandemic now just as we're coming
into recovery we're seeing government
planning to raise that vot back up to 20
we want to see that reduced vat made
permanent
culture secretary Nadine Doris says the
government will continue to back the
music industry every step of the way but
for critics it isn't just concern about
covert alone but the combined impact
alongside Arts education cuts the Trump
pipeline of really successful musicians
that we've had in the case and in danger
of being choked off I think what it
needs government is to actually sit down
and understand the sector listen to the
boy who work in it
in a sector where three quarters are
self-employed many weren't covered by
government support schemes the reality
is that the vast majority of artists are
Independent Artists like myself or
artists trying to forge a career and we
need support for a new generation of
artists and for Independent Artists this
is
[Music]
safety net of support not only do we
risk losing the next big British star
but also the industry that comes with it
Katie Spencer Sky News
[Music]
um you're wondering where those pictures
are aren't you uh from La Palma here
they are have a quick look
oh my God these are live I'm guessing
down are they yeah I think these are
live pictures oh my goodness should we
have a quick listen
it's amazing isn't it and it has been
erupting now for more than four weeks
we're told seven thousand people on the
island have been displaced a lot of this
lava Finds Its way down to the Sea and
toxic gas as a result so only 30 or a
thousand people actually live on the
island something like 1700 properties
have been evacuated so far
um but it does look as though oh my
goodness looks as though it will
continue on for some time to come is
what we're being told by a volcanologist
we spoke to one didn't we last week I
think and we said that we would check up
with them again this week didn't we
Laura will get on that for you um have a
look have another quick listen it's
really really dramatic stuff
wow
yeah I don't think that is subsiding any
day soon is that keeping an eye on that
for you and we'll track down that
volcanologist
um as well nothing like that at home as
far as the weather is concerned here in
fact it's going to be pretty mild pretty
unsettled thanks to a southwesterly wind
and it's going to turn colder from
tomorrow
yay
oh no that's Kanye isn't it mixing them
up
I'm here all week try the veil the
government announces plans to offer
households five thousand pound grants to
swap their gas boiler for a low carbon
heat pump talking to Caroline Lucas
green MP and member of the House of
Commons environmental audit select
committee next
[Music]
people will be able to apply
I'm being told for Grants of several
thousand pounds to ditch their gas
boiler and change to heating that
produces lower emissions or part of the
government's plan to hit its climate
targets earlier I spoke to the
international trade secretary Anne-Marie
trevelyn and asked her if it was going
to be a voluntary scheme
of course this is a voucher scheme but
every you know 10 to 15 years and I've
spoken to my local gas teams about this
we all get a new boiler there is a
changing of the equipment doesn't last
forever so as part of as I say the
transition this journey to Net Zero as
we as domestic citizens make changes to
our homes these support Frameworks these
Financial Frameworks are there but also
we will be driving those changes in
regulations so that the next time you
maybe want to change the boiler in your
home the opportunity will be to either
have a heat pump or indeed perhaps as I
have a hydrogen ready boiler so that
this will be part of the transition
Thomas Tamara's here
I don't know whose teeth I'm going today
but let's see let's hope it improves um
tell me what you made of what and Marie
trevelyn had to say so this is a big
strategy they've been waiting for for a
long time because to slash our emissions
we need to make big changes to our homes
and Lifestyles and the government are
going to provide 5 000 pound grants for
us to get rid of our gas boilers and to
have these more environmentally friendly
heat pumps instead now Boris Johnson is
at Payne's to say he's writing in the
sun today you won't have to no green
police are going to rip your boiler out
and force you to have one we just hope
that when your boiler comes to the end
of its life you will consider the
benefit of investing in one of these now
Anne Marie trevelyn said it will be
voluntary in the short term suggesting
they might want to make a compulsory
down the line but that depends on all
the economics working out because the
amount of money they put into it would
allow around 90 000 households to have
one of these obviously if we're all
intended to have one by 2035 they're
going to have to really step it Up all
the costs are going to have to fall
dramatic basically because they cost
more than five grand now so that means
putting in some money yourself and she
talked about those who want to crack on
getting the chance to but the question
is when will this filter down to
everybody else and she pointed out that
for it to really work your home needs to
be insulated and there is no plan for
the government to pay for that at
present okay but now tomorrow thanks
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock this
morning thank you uh joining us the
David King chair of the climate crisis
Advisory Group hello Tuesday David thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning
um so we all should have these heat
pumps or the equivalent and they're
going to cost about ten thousand pounds
each the government has got enough for
90 000 Homes at 5 000 pounds a piece
maths is not there as yes is it
foreign
this is a very small step in the right
direction so I've got to first of all
welcome it but you're you're you're
quite right 90 000 homes is uh is not
going to get across to the British
public in general and the the question
of Home insulation but there's a a very
big agenda here as we uh green our
economy which we have to do this is an
investment in our future we really have
to have a comprehensive policy so what
what are we doing about uh home
insulation what are we doing about our
continued use of gas for electricity
production is that going to eventually
also be wiped out and at what are the
timelines on all of us yes we know that
our boilers have a lifetime and we
shouldn't replace them before they're
ready to be replaced but can we be sure
that nobody will replace their boilers
with old-fashioned boilers instead of
these new ones I think the voluntary
nature of the scheme threatens its its
rollout but I really want to see a
comprehensive strategy on deep emissions
reduction the Prime Minister made a
promise at the G7 this year saying we
will reduce our emissions by 70 78 by
2035.
78 and we're close on 50 now how does he
make up the gap between where we are now
and that's 78 percent I'm not
criticizing the 78 it was an excellent
announcement but we as a government we
can't look in two directions we've
really got to set out a comprehensive
strategy from moving right away from
fossil fuels we've been very successful
and this is not a tribute to this
government but to Prior governments in
ruling out the use of coal for
electricity production and then we get
an announcement of a possible new Coal
Mine in Cumbria so we we're really not
being coherent and what is required is
an investment in our future is that we
have a coherent strategy
um mean Greta tomberg you'll know when
she heard the 78 percent uh figure from
Boris Johnston said and I'm quoting her
blah blah blah do you agree
I think Greta is a wonderful
spokesperson so what what she says
should be making the politicians think
we got promises from 197 nations in 2015
that they would reduce emissions there
is not one country in the world and I
have to include Britain that has
delivered on all of their promises now
what what we need is considerably more
than was promised in 2015 but for
example
the wealthy countries agreed in 2009 to
fund a hundred billion dollars a year
into a green climate fund based in Seoul
to assist the developing countries of
the world to make a transition and to
prepare for the challenges of climate
change
that has never happened it has never
been more than a total sitting in that
budget of 20 billion dollars let alone
100 billion dollars a year
that is blah blah blah what we have to
show is that we can deliver and let's
hold the politicians feet to the fire we
really cannot afford to fall back on
this because frankly we are in a climate
crisis the future looks very Bleak
unless we can persuade our politicians
to really deliver on this
um can I just ask you to pop your
International Sage
um
um hat on I don't mean International do
I mean independent
um
and as far as boosters are concerned uh
I did put that to the minister as well
and she said that she was reasonably
happy with the roller of the booster
scheme um and yet we've had 40 000
people uh test positive for covid
yesterday what do you think
I think the booster scheme has rolled
been rolled out extremely slowly it's
very surprising given the success of the
vaccination scheme which was conducted
through the NHS in a an amazingly
professional way which we would expect
from the NHS as distinct from the test
creation isolate scheme pushed into new
private sector companies that couldn't
possibly deliver on time so we we've had
disastrous operations but I I think the
the booster rollout I've had my booster
but I do know many older people who
haven't yet had their booster and so it
I cannot understand this if if the
vaccines are available what's happening
to the rollout
and why do you think why do you think it
is I mean I went for mine a couple of
weeks ago very well organized shout out
to my local booster Center
um vaccine clinic they were absolutely
amazing a well-oiled machine but I was
also surprised that there weren't as
many people there as when I'd had my
other two previous inoculations if you
don't have your booster what does that
mean with the winter ahead
well I think I think the the the
government would be right to roll this
booster scheme out properly I have
exactly the same experience as you I
went along I was treated very quickly
because there weren't that many people
there but it was all very a very
efficient operation professionally run
but I I think what what is the danger
we're faced with we're seeing it already
the number of new cases per day at close
to 40 000 per day and we soon will have
the big climate change cup meeting in
Glasgow where we're expecting maybe 25
30 000 people certainly there will be
about four thousand negotiators there
and then the the rest of the people who
attend these meetings and we're also by
the way hearing about uh people walking
in the streets maybe a hundred thousand
of them
I think that's going to be a massive
potential uh rollout of the disease it's
it's a viral Factory to put all those
people together from 197 nations of the
world so I I really worry about it not
because they will bring disease in to us
but because we are the country with a
very high level of virus and we will be
passing it on to them and then off they
go back to their country so I I think
it's uh really been badly in run how
many people are still wearing masks and
for goodness sake why not I just don't
understand why when I get into a train
or an underground I don't see everybody
wearing masks it's a very simple
operation we got over any fear of
wearing masks many many months ago why
aren't we still requiring people to
travel with mouse to go into buildings
with masks it just seems a very simple
thing
and the the the the diseases is rising
to yet another Peak and this peak could
be as serious as the last
[Music]
okay thanks for taking the time to join
us this morning thank you Caroline Lucas
green party MP for Brighton Pavilion is
with us are you have you had uh you're
not old enough to have your booster yet
but you've been um double-jabbed How
concerned are you before we get on to a
climate change about what's happening uh
with 40 000 people uh registered has
having contracted covert yesterday
well I share sir David's concerns I
think it is deeply worrying that the
government isn't setting a much better
example frankly just have a quick look
at the House of Commons and you just see
rows and rows of people certainly on the
government side with no mask at all I
don't see why so David said we're not uh
having masks in crowded places in public
transport and so forth I think as well
that we need to get ventilation much
better ventilation in our schools still
hasn't been rolled out at the speed that
it needs and I recognize of course that
there is an issue with having been one
of the first countries to get those
vaccinations it also means that we need
to to get the boosters fast and so we
certainly need to be looking at what's
going wrong in terms of rolling that out
more effectively but I think there is a
cause for concern here and I think the
government is showing a remarkable
complacency
uh something uh that we also need to
roll out as certainly as far as your
concern and the government will be
making the point later on today are
these um heat pumps
um but it is going to be voluntary at
least for now is what we heard from the
government Minister this morning do you
think that's the right way forward
no I don't and I think everyone's in a
bit of shock this morning to be honest
because we all thought that there was
going to be a legal requirement by a
certain date in the 2030s whether that's
2032 or 2035 but beyond that date there
would be uh it would be legally
impossible to buy a new gas boiler now
we're just hearing that the government
is is backtracking on that and I think
what you can see here really is the
impact of An Almighty route between the
treasury and number 10 and the treasury
has clearly won and therefore the
funding that's really required to to get
these heat pumps into people's homes
fast enough simply isn't there so I
think that's one real concern that we
don't have the funding to really scale
up at the kind of pace that we need on
these heat pumps and secondly it seems
just such an extraordinary Mission not
to have put in at the same package a
really comprehensive home insulation
scheme we know that heat pumps are only
going to work well if your home is
insulated and there simply isn't enough
money in this package to properly
insulate homes either so I'm afraid this
is yet another of course Johnson's you
know big Flagship policies that when you
start to look at some of the details
they're simply not there and that on the
eve of the of the cop climate Summit
this big Glasgow Summit in in a couple
of weeks time I think that's sending a
very bad signal
and as far as insulation homes is
concerned I mean do you still think that
it's a good idea for environmental
protesters to sit down and block the M25
I've said before that I think what they
should be blocking is the treasury I
mean I think we need to be putting the
the the the the pressure on those people
who are making these decisions it's not
motorists on the M25 who are making
decisions about rolling out insulation
it's Rishi Chancellor the fossil fuel
Chancellor uh in the uh in the treasury
so that's all we need to be putting
pressure I'm really sorry that it looks
as if the treasury has won out in the
battle over whether or not enough
funding is going to be put in into this
program you only have to compare the UK
with other countries in terms of how
we're doing uh rolling out
um heat pumps you know we've basically
only put out around a quarter of the
heat pumps that they have in Germany a
sixth of the number that they have in in
Italy a tenth of the number in France so
we're really lagging behind other
European countries this was the
opportunity to scale up at the speed uh
at hand at the scale that the science
demands and the government's splunked it
and that is a real tragedy both for all
of those people who are living in field
poverty who can't afford to keep their
homes warm but also in terms of our
climate emissions as well well the kind
of insulation program that so many
people want to see this comprehensive
Street by Street local authority-led
program would not only get people's
emissions down it will get their fuel
bills down but it would also create
hundreds of thousands of jobs in every
single constituency in the country it is
a massively lost opportunity you're not
suggest advocating I should say the
blocking of government buildings though
are you really
I'm advocating when it's necessary
peaceful direct action and I've never
been afraid to do that and I've taken
that kind of action myself to block a
government building that'd be illegal
wouldn't it
um the the whole point about peaceful
direct action is that that you create
some kind of obstruction what I'm simply
saying is that rather than if you're
going to treasury would be illegal
some sometimes there are bigger
illegalities we're facing at the moment
the issue of an existential threat to
life on Earth I think that in that
context if people do choose to take
peaceful direct action they're
legitimate to do that they take the the
legal consequences what I'm suggesting
okay if I could just finish what I'm
suggesting is
a robust conversation you're advocating
people breaking the law blocking the
doors to the treasury and I'm saying
that's illegal
um and I'm asking you to
um say whether you uh advocating people
acting in an illegal way for the greater
good is that what you're saying
I'm saying that sometimes when there is
a greater illegality if you like if you
think about our legal commitments to to
get our emissions down if you think
about the fact that climate change poses
an existential threat to life on Earth
I'm saying that sometimes there are
occasions when peaceful direct action is
legitimate even if that means breaking
the law if it's done in a peaceful way
I'm saying that rather than blocking the
M25 where what you're essentially doing
is putting yourself in the way of of
people who have absolutely no influence
over government policy if people are
choosing to take that kind of action it
would make an awful lot more sense to do
it when the people that they are
focusing on are the decision makers
right now we've got a decision maker in
the treasury the chancellor who is not
putting the funding behind the kind of
program that we need to see to get our
homes insulated to shift away from the
fossil fuel economy that is one of the
most serious issues that we face today
and I'm saying that I think if people do
take peaceful direct action in that
cause then I I could quite understand
why they would do that yeah but it can't
be legitimate if it's illegal that's an
oxymoron
no it's not uh the suffragettes the um
civil rights movement and they got
arrested they were arrested and then the
law was subsequently changed but it was
illegal so they were arrested
I'm not I'm not arguing about whether
it's legal or not what I'm arguing about
yeah you were you said it was legitimate
action it's not legitimate if it's
illegal
that's where I'm differing with UK I'm
saying that there can be action that is
both legal uh illegal and legitimate in
certain circumstances I'm certainly not
advocating it lightly but I am saying
for example when I was arrested for
intervening um sitting down outside a
fracking protest I was subsequently uh
found to to to not have committed a
crime but I sat down there I was
arrested for that I was prepared to take
the legal consequences because fracking
was on the front line of a whole new
fossil fuel uh industry I think that
right now when literally what we're
talking about is the livability of this
planet going forward I would not want to
be able to look into the eyes of future
generations and explain why I didn't
take every peaceful action that I could
to try to make sure that we get our
emissions down right now what we're
talking about is this government's new
uh plan the sadness is the tragedy is
that the plan is not going to be enough
to get us where we need to be even
according to the government's own
advisors the committee on climate change
and therefore I think it is right that
people make as much noise as possible to
try to put pressure on the government to
step up and put in place the policies
that we need
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time and arguing the case
from your perspective this morning much
appreciated as always thank you
as President Joe Biden faces big trouble
ahead of cop26 as one of his own
Senators continues to block the progress
of a multi-trillion dollar clean energy
bill Joe mention a moderate from West
Virginia says the bill contains Clauses
that could hurt his State's coal mining
industry as our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone reports
could this be the man to Scupper key
American pledges at the Glasgow climate
conference a senator from West Virginia
Joe manchin is a name we could hear lots
over the coming days a conservative
Democrat sticking up for his coal
Reliant state workers but at what cost
for our changing climate over the other
side of the Atlantic you are now being
cast as as the man the politician who
may Scupper the cop climate conference
what's your response to that no I said
my goodness we've done more for climate
and changed the climate basically in
America faster than any other country on
Earth but you're watering down not one
thing no no you're talking about one
thing the clean energy standard correct
PCP yes paying utilities 150 billion
dollars yeah but you are watering down a
very very ambitious climate no not at
all you're you need to read the facts
and see what's happening in the world
look what happens in China what's
happening in Russia look what's going on
over in your country coal is still a
central part of the American Energy
sector and the landscape gape across the
country in West Virginia most industry
workers are in the mines coal fuels the
economy in one of the country's poorest
states where Senator manchin is also an
investor in the industry
Joe Biden is trying to push a huge 3.5
trillion dollar bill through Congress
crucially it contains big climate change
pledges earlier this month Biden's
climate Envoy John Kerry told Sky News
of the sweeping plan to decarbonize
America's energy sector the sausage
making is not pretty
but in the end they're going to have a
sausage I believe the question now is
will they you want those coal mines in
your in your state to stay able to make
sure we have reliable power we have we
have basically cleaned up the
environment more than any other time in
the history of this world so the coal
the coal plants they can all close in
your in your state they're not going to
close in the state you can't close them
with reliability
we need reliability America's ability to
hit its carbon reduction targets and its
ability to persuade other nations to do
the same now rests here on Capitol Hill
where the pledge is to save the planet
are up against politics people and jobs
markstone Sky News in Washington
producing
Maldives has welcomed more than 900 000
tourists this year despite only opening
its border to international travel in
July figures from the tourism Ministry
of the Maldives reveal arrivals are more
than 102 22 higher than in 2020 joined
now by the minister of Tourism for the
Maldives that's Abdullah masum hello to
you thank you for joining us why do you
think so many people are coming to the
Maldives
is loved by tourists because we have got
such a beautiful product and uh after
they call it when the world was closed
we were open and we were able to do a
very good experience the tourists who
came here they showed the world that
mold is open The New Normal is very
normal in the world so uh we we are
welcoming more tourists day by day and
we are happy that uh finally uh UK has
given green light for the Maldives and
we look forward to having a very
humanful season in the coming months and
also India 2022.
what's the vaccine real life been like
on the Maldives
oh it has been fantastic because uh the
government gave a very high priority for
the industry
um workers so the tourism sector employs
99 percent has taken their first dose
and 93 percent of Lee vaccination and
the population at large also very much
vaccinated and uh the life is very
normal now you can ask from the tourists
you can see the posts by it's amazing
Minister I'm so sorry we are out of time
thank you so much for showing those
pictures with us um we'll see at the top
of the hour taking you to Bermuda next
week
[Music]